[Music]
enjoying nature news submitted by katie
loves JK Thank You Katie
a businessman in the UAE wants to solve
their water crisis by towing an iceberg
from Antarctica to the Arabian Gulf yo
you took my business idea really so I
wanted to I wanted to have an igloo
business in LA in the summer to keep it
cold right so we would get glues from
Alaska or wherever they're from maybe
North Canada you know have it shipped
over here right it's hot as hell check
this so people are gonna want to be in
the cold but it's gonna melt so every
year do you buy another [ __ ]
igloo that's great cuz then you
regenerate your business Miller and I
have returned customers because it'll be
like honey wasn't it so nice but we had
a it look hell yeah it was so nice let's
get it again this year and then I could
make a [ __ ] celebration out of it like
I don't know honey are you it was
getting pretty melty yeah but you know
what it was nice and cold remember that
yeah that was nice
took my idea well also it'll very nicely
cool the ocean around it this is being
dragged through I think it's no that's
what I think too
Oh like a big ice cube yeah and all the
boats are gonna have a little water
problems on this side environmentally
safe water ice what's happening why is
there a crisis of the UAE here we go
thank they rich well okay so right now
about water they they are currently dry
the camels drink it all it is a dry ass
place yeah just trying to help brain top
and brain star notice again like 105
yeah like the Middle East yeah so they
keep her there in the country of ooh
they consume around 15% of the world's
desalinated water what why so much
they're [ __ ] thirsty they don't have
a lot of fresh water way to call them
out man the water crisis though have you
seen their country it's some small
it's like a psycho Hawaii they're very
rich they're the very thirsty they like
their bottled water you do now maybe
it's hot and dry so they need a drink
more yeah
fifty percent of the world's water
supply what it's so small yeah so
they're saying that the process to do
selling me the water it affects the
environment very negatively because they
have to put that salt somewhere and so
it ends up being a huge amount of brine
water in the Gulf which makes the heavy
water very high and the kills of fish
and it stinks this happened in a little
town called the Salton Sea in California
oh that place smells like [ __ ] and
that's what happened to those Ritchie
fans camera place well that's been
happening there yeah so then because of
that this businessman he had too much
money and time on his hands he has this
idea he wants to make happen that he
will be they'll be scanning us out with
satellite for this huge iceberg that's
two kilometers by five hundred meters
with that I don't know in America is
like about a mile mile long and you
wants to drag it yeah so you wants to
they're saying that it will take about
ten months and they will lose about 30%
of the mass by the time your beaches
yeah but they will they're trying to so
he's saying that this would be very
beneficial and it would actually cost
less to do this than to continue what
they're doing and they're saying that
the a preliminary test is expected to
cost between sixty to eighty million
dollars but the entire thing to go
through would be a hundred to 150 but
can I just be taken America's ice like
that alright don't they just [ __ ] me
no that's a loose iceberg right why
don't we take a bunch of them and then
we can cool all the oceans down by
dragging them all over the article where
Santa lives well apparently we're losing
arnica anyway yeah so let's just speed
up yeah Mars will cool down the rest of
you can't Pangea ourselves I just want
to enjoy life while I got it
I don't give a [ __ ] about who comes next
until I have kids you hear that plastic
straws and turtles young Google oh I
don't like this master plastic straws
[ __ ] best I [ __ ] hate these people
practice stroke [ __ ] man I hate that
shapeless draws soft dude 70 to 90% of
recycled things don't actually recycle
and I've been the ship landfills yep
you know bury our trash they're not even
recycle ball I was telling Nicky that
[ __ ] she's like I gotta recycle this
young man you wasting your [ __ ] time
and I showed her that [ __ ] and she's
like oh dang
yeah microplastics single-use plastics
that's what you gotta cut out in order
to make an actual more energy is used
recycling then [ __ ] when you're mean
like you got to burn fuel you have to do
all these it it's just like your Tesla's
like you're the [ __ ] battery for
those things that cost so much
environmentally to even produce them as
someone who has it but I learned that
it's better to keep your car than by any
of rechargeable car why because you're
using the life of your car it costs less
and less resources than to build a new
brand new energy-efficient car so we're
[ __ ]
little known fact yeah you guys are you
have a Tesla you triple [ __ ] I like
it I would buy 100 I didn't I [ __ ]
answering emails oh that's where I'm at
on PI's extraña - I might give you my
POSIX draw funny joke there's like what
would happen though if we didn't have
tools we just wouldn't have Turtles
right exactly
[ __ ] I like turtles I swam with other
monkey's tight I like turtles
I like the turtles but I've never seen a
turtle with this [ __ ] straw and it's
mouthing Hawaii we also wipeout
mosquitoes which kills mosquito here she
use those prongs cause the crazy
strongly you know what's [ __ ] up about
mosquito I kill the [ __ ] it's a lot of
the bendy one mosquitoes are invasive a
lot of it beg dated they're not mate
they're not natural to Hawaii who did it
well so they killed except for our
[ __ ] happiness what I'll say do you
know they're the number one killer of
their disease human disease their DS we
gotta kill them where they kill us a
slice thing I do
I would love to do do any human wait
what are you talking about
Oh know what every point well why did it
tell you more about this thing you know
this glacier idea oh [ __ ] that's very
you have a scar in his face but he
looked like a [ __ ] gangster do ya why
is it no that's a scar no that's a scar
yeah probably a birthmark that's it
so this is like he's saying that it will
be a mile long that's a big boy well the
screen the screen is 15 inches that's
right asking but yeah so they're saying
that they're gonna do this like circular
thing to like Corral it and then it will
end up in the gold perfect salad it's
not [ __ ] moving bike well first we
gotta corral the animal that has no legs
where's the soul that was my word that
I'm sorry so by the time that ice gets
there it's gonna completely [ __ ]
mouth how do they know it's gonna be 30%
yeah we did a preliminary test no and
then also they're saying that's water
that's the the amount of water that
they'll be able to get from this iceberg
will last for five years but what about
what does it do where they're taking it
yeah Santa in order to live and then we
all have to go Jewish no because if it
is you're in the right place yeah
whatever
Ark dick so truth is shattered and I'm
happy it happened here yeah point is is
we should just be borrowing [ __ ] like
that they're not they're taking it
doesn't have melting it back into the
ocean I don't know if that counts if
it's going into people's mouths and
going out as cool it's to stop the ice
caps from melting they're like come on
come to the hottest place out at France
courting they put their flag on it so
it's ER so should we tell they stop
drinking so much water I think so we
need to find a lot
question is why are they so thirsty
potato chips there say the UN is saying
that there would eat that and you drink
more water Steve air conditioning in
Dubai so the UN is saying that by 2030
there will be 40% less fresh water like
there'll be a shortfall of fresh water
why don't they start the filtering
process now like no that's what they
have been doing the desalination but
doing that you have to put this all
tomorrow what about like the [ __ ] and
stuff like they have that technology now
where they get the human waste and they
[ __ ] turn it and turn it and burn it
and do all kinds of [ __ ] - and Sarah and
Rama and that's what our water system
take ten years and then it's drinkable
like well they do - they release that
water back into the ocean after they
treat do that with tampon water like
when you flush tampons it's like you're
not supposed to flush tampons people
[ __ ] do ok if you learned anything
for these other anyway there's a company
that's trying to turn it and turn it and
burn it and bring it in today hey and
then we can drink tampon water have you
seen the video of Bill Gates drinking
his own pee no it was that mud water
thing right well no it was his own piss
but he's big it's clean was it going
no bad but I'm saying that he's like
proud he's like I'm drinking my cuz
their life so like easy they're like I'm
crazy
earth science teacher told me 10 years
ago that the next war is gonna be on
water about water water rights yeah why
don't we figure if we can put a man on
the moon why can't we figure out another
boy put a man on the moon though not
hell not another formal I don't know so
now they're saying this whole like
iceberg thing to there that it will so
they based on their environmental
assessments that minimal impact was done
in the ecosystem as well as the
environment by like removing the iceberg
and placing it in the Gulf 30 did it no
no not like their their tests I don't
know yeah of course they're gonna say
that they can't run their own [ __ ]
tests and be like you see you need a
third part
I love government agencies investigating
themselves and saying hey we're cool
completely dump is actually dumping them
we thought yeah you know what we're just
saving the environment they're also not
anything that they will and saving lots
of money it could lead to more rain in
the neighboring desert which will
benefit the future and so they're saying
that it will cause a weather pattern
change and it will attract clouds to
move into the Arabian Sea
it's like terraforming we just need
another Ice Age that's all
Bob you sir will solve many PI like you
want more tourism why you come see the
facial how many animals is that
glistening so more people need to drink
water are you thinking why don't they
just buy a bunch of water bottles like
we do just go to Costco Vanessa yeah we
sell a lot of water I'm sure we could
spare some for them this idea was
proposed by French scientists to Saudi
Arabia some say in 1975 oh but it failed
two years later due to technical reasons
and so that's why this businessman is
like right now Chernobyl what do you do
you you put a spike down and you drag it
with a chain yeah remember all right
they Corral it
[Music]
[Music]